welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the youtuber
that's a pretty cool guy like mr. freeze
and we're back after a long hiatus we
finally have an update and when the
Batman can resume filming as well as
some amazing updates in regards to the
film throughout this video we'll be
breaking down new reports discussing the
Batmobile concept images Jeff frost
posted a new interview with Paul Dano on
the film and some of the plot leaks
there may be some spoilers here so if
you want to go into the movie as blind
as a bat or if you're just testing your
eyesight by driving to Barnard castle
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now if you're still here make sure
you subscribe to the channel to never
miss a video and please drop a thumbs up
if you enjoy the content without the way
as always thank you for clicking this
now let's get into our Batman updates
breakdown okay so with the UK slowly
starting to ease itself out of lockdown
thanks to Dominic Cummings giving us the
go-ahead to do whatever we want the film
industry is set to return throughout all
parts of England Wales Scotland and
Northern Ireland films and TV shows were
put on hold due to the pandemic but
things are slowly starting to get back
to normal and according to a new report
by the Guardian filming can resume on a
lot of projects in July this is of
course amazing news for fans of the film
and those that work in the industry as
many are actually freelance and thus
they've been struggling for the last
couple of months due to being ineligible
for financial support however things
won't be returning back to normal just
yet and the British Film Commission is
drawn of reels that include physical
distancing safety training and regular
tests to make sure that all staff can
work in a safe environment I think it'll
be weird for actors who have to go from
the makeup chair where they are closely
worked on for then standing opposite
someone in the scene and thus these
meshes have to be put in place to ensure
your safety
though Warner Brothers haven't
officially announced when filming is
going to resume the Guardian does state
that they are keen to restart production
on fantastic beasts and the Batman which
are both due for release next year an
industry source at the Guardian named
John brew dude trust me told the paper
many productions have to get up and
running again in the next two months or
they won't get made this year as they
rely on summer weather and conditions so
from this it is likely that Warner
Brothers will want to initiate
production as soon as they can in next
month I must I must remember to switch
to Chromebook as well anyway obviously
they have to fly some of their stars
from the US over and if the UK is
actually enforcing its two-week lockdown
from the airport then that means that
they will have to start moving them
within the next two weeks in order to
get them ready for July how do you think
that filming will resume in July but
more likely towards the end of the month
as sets have to once more be assembled
and also filming permission has to be
reapplied foreign grantees we did start
to see some outdoor sets being built
just as things were shutting down and
these once more will have to be put back
up which it looks like I'll take a while
by the way if I say that anywhere I'm
stealing it I'll of course give you a
definite date once we have it but at the
moment I would speculate that it will be
mid to late July before everything fully
resumes let's just hope we don't go back
into lockdown or we could be seeing the
movie released much later than 2021
anyway we also have some more images and
information on the Batmobile that helped
us piece together exactly how it will
look these come from concept model maker
jeff frost who's also worked on the Star
Trek reboot Tomorrowland the Mission
Impossible series and more it gives us a
really good look at the car after the
officially released photos were hidden
mainly in shadow and the dimly lit
environment that the vehicle was housed
in now the first thing I want to draw
attention to is the almost battering ram
like front of the car this really
highlights to me how it will be used as
a weapon itself rather than the things
that are housed within it when we did
our first breakdown on the vehicle we
did say that due to the size of the
engine that this beast had clearly been
built for speed there was a lot of focus
given to the back of the car which was
clearly going to be used to propel it at
great speeds towards wherever it was
heading the fact that the front is built
like this makes me now think that this
is literally just a battering ram on
wheels that will be used to smash
through walls and doors so that Batman
can gain access to places to me this
heightens its use
imagine how intimidating it would be to
play chicken with this thing when it's
coming at you at full speed and you can
either get out of its way or go under
its wheels the entire thing looks like
it's built just to smash things with as
much brute force as possible
no people initially thought that it
would be one of the weakest Batmobiles
due to it just being a car with an
engine I think that these images clearly
highlight that the car might actually be
one of the most powerful versions as its
sole purpose seems just to be to smash
things it's definitely the kind of
vehicle that would smash that like
button and if you love it then you
should - no no that's that's the dislike
button now but I'm really impressed with
how good it looks and seeing it like
this makes it seem like one of the
best-looking versions of the car ever
I'm sure this model is getting shipped
out to Hasbro as we speak because it
looks absolutely brilliant it's very
sleek and modern but it also has a
classic feel to it that reminds me of
just how timeless Batman can be overall
I'm very hype for it and hopefully it
drives as good as it looks
top speed 20 miles per hour now before
we get into the rest of the video I just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the marble phase 3 part 2
box set to one random subscriber all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts and
the updates in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random
and the 15th of June and the settle be
shipped out from the intro ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part and finally Paul Dano who
has remained relatively quiet about the
entire thing has finally broken his
silence on what exactly is going on in
an interview with the playlist Donna
said I was filming I flew home to visit
my baby and then didn't get to fly back
to set because of coronavirus which is a
really strange thing but I feel really
good about it
I think Matt Reeves is the real deal I
was really surprised by his script which
i think is potentially really powerful
hopefully we'll get to see it back
sometime soon I'm not sure so no further
clarity on exactly when filming will
resume but from this we can take that
the script will be extremely powerful
that he's confident in both Matt Reeves
his ability and the storyline itself the
other plot is being kept firmly under
wraps we do
some specific things about it at the
moment due to leaks again we will be
spoiling some key aspects of the film so
if you don't want anything potentially
ruined then we recommend that you turn
off now be still here apparently the
movie will be a year 2 storyline that
shares a lot of similarities with the
earth 1 arc by Jeff Jones the man and DA
are both murdered which sends Gotham
into complete turmoil Batman
investigates these deaths and discovers
that they were caused by the Riddler who
is slowly starting to take over Gotham
on top of this we also know that Jamie
Lawson is playing Bela rial who is a
mayoral candidate so it does look like
there will be a power struggle within
Gotham and though this hasn't been
hinted at I do think that the penguin
will be running in opposition to her if
you have a mayoral candidate then by
definition you have to have an election
storyline and now I'm just joining the
dots here to me at least it's one of the
conclusions that seems the most obvious
a penguin hasn't been confirmed as doing
any of this but in several adaptations
on the character both in comics and
live-action he has run for the position
every time I brought this up the the
response I get from someone has always
been well it happened in Batman Returns
so it's too soon to do it again
however Batman Returns was released in
1992 and when the Batman releases in
2021 it will have almost been 30 years
since the second Tim Burton film dropped
the prior big storyline of penguin
becoming the mayor was in the 1966
Batman show which was released 26 years
prior to returns so if we are doing the
two soon argument then we also have to
be aware that there's precedent for it
happening even sooner and other
adaptations what I'm trying to say is
that any story involving a run for
election that also features the penguin
inevitably has to have him going for the
mass job Batman becomes even more
powerless if this is achieved by the
villain and I would love to see him
having to fight criminals on the street
whilst also going head-to-head with the
seemingly untouchable politicians again
none of this has been confirmed but it
does seem likely to me in the wake of
the character list and the things that
we know about the movie time will of
course tell but yeah from what we know
I'd say it was just common sense
and obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the updates when you think
the movie will
soon filming whether you like the
Batmobile or not and your thought on the
plot leaks comment below and let me know
and I also just want to give a shout out
to Brooklyn Batman Torres on John EMP
and the bat sauce on Twitter who've been
massively sharing my links and getting
them out there it doesn't go unnoticed
and I really appreciate it as I
appreciate all of you guys checking out
the videos week by week if you missed
our breakdown or rather breakup last
week of the news that the Batman was
canceled then I highly recommend that
you check it out right after this it's a
bit more of a funnier video so you might
have a bit of fun in these dark and
troubling times if you want to support
the channel from his letter is 99 cents
a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat yourself to
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways to keeper today with the channel so
hopefully we see over there very soon
and tell you what have a lovely day as
well all the best to you take care I
know I know it's really tough out there
right now and it's crazy to see what the
world's turned into but you know my
hearts with you and we can do it take
care love ya
[Music]